[Music]
you know the ladies have owned this
season of The Bachelor but they kicked
it up to a whole new level last night
during the women tell all
yeah things got totally crazy but I mean
vine sees it got even crazier with ETO
lines lauren zima i don't think that you
fully realized the impact that the
things that you've said had because it's
had a direct impact on my life
we saw Taylor and Corrine go at it on
camera but what you didn't see
producers stepping into console Taylor
after the cameras stopped rolling you
laugh now and you can't even like try
and express any kind of empathy what
about you Taylor run I didn't take their
claims her feud with Corinne is to blame
for her struggles with her career last
month she told us it got so bad she had
to walk away from her practice as a
mental health counselor it's definitely
taken a toll emotionally sometimes I
feel really low and I feel like I'm
never gonna be able to work again as a
counselor how are you feeling about your
relationship with Taylor after tonight
how are you guys walking away um my
relationship with Taylor you know
whatever it's deaded it's done there's
no turning back right now we should
blame don't apologize sorry
Corinne seemed to dominate refusing to
apologize and getting a lot of support
on and off camera from the rest of the
girls Hey you walk around the house like
you were too good for everything until
nap gate came up you're telling America
you're taking a nap
babies take naps I know all the
accusations are brought to me tonight
gorillas grow up she took the initiative
she took risks maybe to some of those
risks opened herself up for criticism
but she still took him Nick was clearly
Team Quran last night even as he took
his lumps with some of the girls on
stage where device don't talk to one of
your like kind of girlfriends about your
other kind of girlfriend backstage he
had a real sweet moment with new
bachelorette Rachel I did sense a little
bit of chemistry still between you and
Nick what was it like seeing him it
brought back a lot of emotions it was
bittersweet
and something else you didn't see on
camera the drinks were flowing during
the almost seven hours it took to tape
the show Korean ask producers to bring
her glasses of champagne during
commercial breaks something she says
production did for her every day while
filming The Bachelor whenever I wanted
it woke up boom there was great thank
you have a great day and dolphin
enthusiasts Alexis made this confession
to us backstage Alexis how many shots of
fireball have you guys keep sleepy too
many good way to many part of the magic
is the alcohol it becomes a cocktail of
emotion well
[Music]
you